All right. Hello everyone. We should be
recording now. So it's May 29th, 2026.
We're here with the fundamentals of
active inference reading group and we're
going through chapter 3. We're hopefully
going to finish chapter 3 today. Go
through the latter half of uh of that
chapter. So we've actually seen probably
most of the uh material. Just going to
sh sh sh sh sh sh sh sh sh sh sh sh sh
sh share my screen here. Hopefully the
entire screen. I I think everyone should
be able to see. I'll just uh quickly
see if I can do that.
So, here in chapter 3, we 3.1 to uh 3.3
last session. Uh now, we're going to go
over 3.4 and 3.5. Basically, they're
they're the remaining parts of the
chapter, and they're really where the
chapter come together uh to produce kind
of the jewel of of the whole chapter,
which is expectation maximization.
That's the the fundamental algorithm
that is the culmination of this chapter.
So as before we have this is the coda
page. You you have your session
objectives there. I've tried to write a
bit of a sort of chapter on a nutshell
type thing. Key shifts in chapter 3 from
chapter 2. And then maybe a bit of a
content breakdown. What's core to the
chapter, what's preview material, what's
deferred for later. And then we have the
map here. I've gone in and I filled in
hadn't done that until recently the 3.4
and 3.5 section 3.4 four and 3.5. So if
you open these, they will do that same
kind of analysis again for the section.
Okay, so section 3.4 this is linear
Gaussian systems. What are they about?
What's the core conceptual shifts? What
are the the things that we should really
be trying to take away? So that's there
for 3.4 and 3.5. Now that should be
especially useful for you for those who
who don't have the book. Um that should
be nice to come back to. All righty.
Oh, it's not going to let me do that.
Get out of that. Okay.
All right. Well, I I want to start in
section 3.4 now. Um perhaps with figure
well the first figure of that section.
Before we do, are there any questions
that remain or that anyone would would
like to to raise just before we do get
started?
Going once, going twice.
No problem. If there aren't,
we may just get stuck again. So the
first
do do raise questions at any point. I'll
I'll come through and uh begin to to uh
address them. I will say actually in
chapter 3 there are quite a few Irata.
So I've gone down here into the Arato as
has Kobas and a few other people and you
can see you know listings that have
chapter 3. There's quite a few of them.
Um so do do be aware of that. Uh if
you're going through the chapter I would
advise you to come here into the Arata
and have a look at certain things. For
instance, I think there's a minor typo
in algorithm 3. Um there's a few other
things as well. So just be bear that in
mind. There do seem to be a few hiata.
Okie do. So well let's start with um 3.4
then I'll scroll back up. Can I scroll?
Yes, I can.
Now the big thing about 3.4. Really the
big thing about chapter 3 in general is
that it's chap, as I said before, it's
chapter 2 redux. We're just doing
chapter 2 again. In some sense, we're
doing hidden state estimation. But of
course in chapter two we assumed we knew
the parameters and now we don't assume
we know the parameters and we have to
learn them in addition. And what we saw
last time is we saw how to how to go
about formulating the problem of
learning parameters in terms of the
setup that we had from chapter 2 which
was we had a single hidden state and
really a single observation modality
that we could uh use to do inference. We
we also learned the parameters with
maximum likelihood estimation in two
different ways either analytically or
with gradient descent. So we went
through that last time. What we're doing
with section 3.4 is we're essentially
going to do that again, but we're going
to now assume that our our hidden states
are multivariate. So they have more than
one thing in them. Okay? They're not
just a number, which is to say, you
know, a food size. It's it's it's a a
list of numbers. Now, so I want to I do
want to share that. Um really in terms
of figures, there is a figure I do want
to show you, but what we're looking at
is equation 3.31.
So we come down here into the equations.
Need to maybe fill these out a little
bit more. They might be a bit sparse,
but 3.31.
That's perfect. This is what we're
looking at. So this is exactly what we
had before where this is our likelihood
right now. Okay, this tells us what's
the probability of an observation given
a hidden state. But the hidden states
are now vectors. They're now lists of
numbers as opposed to just a single
number. And the parameters that we have
are organized into this sort of big
matrix, this table called theta. Uh and
we also have a bias term. So this is
exactly what we saw before. This is a
linear generating function. It's some
number time some vector plus well some
collection of parameters times some
vector plus some more more parameters.
This is a linear generating function.
The only difference from previous
sections is that this is now
multivaried. There's more than one um
thing in the hidden state. So
potentially if we go back to three we
did see this actually prior. So if I
look now, this is uh what we saw in in
3.3 where imagine your hidden state now
has two dimensions to it. Okay, maybe
this is position along some some axis
and this is position on another axis. I
don't know if that's actually I don't
remember if that's true for this
particular example, but this is this
right here. You're looking at an example
of a two-dimensional um hidden stage
problem. So this is now multivariate.
There are multivariables, many
variables. That's the setup we're we're
now looking at.
So mathematically things don't change
too much. Uh 3.31 I want again again I
don't want to I don't want to beguile
you with too much notation. Oh no that's
not what I want.
Three where is it here?
I had it. Not too there we go. 3.31A.
Yeah. So it's exactly the same
mathematically. What's being obscured
from you though is the fact that these
are these are boldfaced things now. So
theta is a bold thing. X is a bold
thing. B is a bold thing. That denotes
that they are now vectors or matrices.
So that what that means is that these
are now multivaried things. They're not
just single numbers. And that's a little
bit obscure just from that notation.
So and correspondingly, so we have our
observation likelihood. What do we also
have? We have our prior belief about
what the hidden states are. Okay? And
the only differences now are that
they're they're multivaried. So maybe
there's two things in my hidden state
belief. what you know hidden state
vector maybe there's three maybe there's
three million whatever I don't know it's
multivaried now that's really the only
change
the this then leads into a very nice
discussion and there's some visual
things to show here about
the and so the gen the general setup in
which this is uh so the name that we
sort of give this procedure where we're
generalizing to many many hidden states
now or multivaried hidden states case is
we went from a linear well a uni-
dimensional linear Gaussian system to a
multi-dimensional
linear gaussian system. So that's that's
exactly what this this uh section is
called. It's called linear Gaussian
systems. All right. So that's all that
is meant by this is that we have our
observation likelihood. We assume it's
linear and we we now are assuming a
multivariate uh
inference problem basically. There's
quite a lot of verbiage to to throw
around. That's that's for sure. I do
want to look at 3.32 and 3.3
3 briefly, but I really want to look at
figure 313
in in particular. That's actually very
important to look at. So, I'm just going
to briefly show um 3.32.
This is exactly what I just showed you,
except now it's actually a bit expanded,
which is always very nice. It may not be
there. 3.32. Uh that may not be one of
the ones that we have.
H no, there it is. Perfect.
Okay, so believe it or not, this is
actually exactly the same thing that I
showed you in terms of the linear
generating function that we saw in the
likelihood. So I just showed you the
likelihood function which was uh 3.31
that was telling us our observations are
generated from hidden states. This is
the likely well the linear generating
function. So we have now a hidden state
which is not one thing but it's three
things. It's a list of three things.
This is called a vector. Okay. And our
parameters they're organized in this
matrix theta. And our bias term that's
also a vector that's that's now
organized in terms of this this here.
And the result of this uh equation this
is a matrix multiplication over here. We
have a matrix or a table times a vector
plus another vector. And that gives us
this over here. In the book, this theta
parameter, this is called the mixing
matrix. And he spends quite a lot of
time on page 67 talking about what this
is. And he says, look, you know, this is
relatively unfamiliar to for us, so it
deserves a closer look. And in figure
3.13, he gives a very nice intuition
about what's going on here
mathematically. Um, so I won't get to
that imminently.
It's not too important to
linger too long on the the details
mathematically, but it is important.
Figure 3.13. So, and again, I would also
stress uh on page 399 in the appendix.
So, that's appendix B, mathematical
notation and modeling setup. He explains
what these indices are. Okay? So, you
know, the the D and the C, what do those
things mean? He explains it there.
Very nice. Hopefully people are
connected. I see a few connection
issues. So, so okay, you know what is D?
D is the observation dimension. All
right. So, it's a list of length D. It's
got D things in it basically. And
similarly for the hidden states, right?
So, hidden state X
this has dimension in this case three.
Okay. So, C is the thing that indexes
hidden state dimension. That means that
the the uh the mixing matrix of our
parameters is a table or a matrix of d
by c things right and what it's going to
do he explains it in the figure I don't
want to read the figure caption maybe
verbatim
uh it's probably not too helpful but the
idea is that okay you've got some you've
got in this case a three element hidden
state what's going to happen well we're
going to take this element of the hidden
state and we're going to multiply it by
whatever weight happens to be in the
mixing matrix and then we're going to
add that to the second element of the
hidden states weighted by the second
element of the the first row of the
mixing matrix and so on with the third
and adding all those things up that will
give us what the first element of the
observation vector should be. So what
what it does is it tells us how to
combine [clears throat]
elements of the the hidden state vector
in a certain way in a certain proportion
that then results in the observation
vector. So this is telling us how hidden
states map to observations. That's kind
of what's happening here and it's done
by means of this linear algebraic uh
machinery whereby we have a matrix
multiplication going on. So I mentioned
that later it's very important to if you
want to understand the mathematical
details you really do have to understand
matrix multiplication. Okay. So this is
the same picture just actually specified
mathematically.
So [clears throat] 3.33 there's they're
sort of split up here.
I want to briefly show that and then I
want to move on because I don't want to
get too uh
3.33 is actually broken up into four
things here. So maybe if I zoom in
it'll be a bit nice. I don't want to
have I don't want to look at them all
individually. So we've got 3.33 A, B, C,
and D. Okay, that's here, right?
This is actually exactly the same
picture that I showed you before in that
matrix equation. Okay, I'm I'm not going
to be able to justify that now, but the
idea is that all right, we've got some
we've got the zerooth element of our
hidden state that has a weight of one.
We have the first element of our hidden
state. Okay, first element of our hidden
state has a weight of one. Second
element of our hidden state has a weight
of minus4. Third element of our hidden
state has a weight of two. We also have
a bias term. That whole thing results in
the first element of the observation
vector. Okay, so this is number one,
first element, number two, number three,
number four. So that's just kind of
expanded with the same view. Exactly the
same ID. So that's the setting that we
are operating in now
back.
Very nice.
uh and then once you do that there is ah
I do I do want to show that [laughter]
once you do that you can get closed form
analytic which is to say mathematical
you know representations of what the
posterior distribution has to be I want
the I want the equations there we go
3.36 is what I want now there we go
perfect
so this is when now what we're doing is
we're saying look we can do inference
and we get our posterior distribution
this is equation 3.36 now a uh and it's
it's the posterior distribution of the
hidden states given our observations
okay so we've done inference to get that
it's just in the multivariate case now
uh so this is this is actually not very
informative to to look at that but if we
look at 3.36 B and C what these things
are this is mathematically speaking the
form of the co-variance that you would
get if you did hidden state inference
with all of these assumptions on a
linear Gaussian uh model.
That's the first well that's the second
parameter of a multivariate
distribution. What's the multivariate
distribution at issue? It's the
posterior. Okay, so it's this here.
You know a multivariate gaussian
distribution takes a coariance and it
takes a mean. Okay, so we saw that's the
expression for the coariance. I don't
want to justify that to you just now.
You can see it's in terms of the uh the
mixing matrix of parameters. It's also
in terms of the precisions on hidden
states and and observations. And then
the mean there's also another expression
for the mean. Okay, so this gives you
exactly what the hidden uh well what the
posterior of the hidden states would be
given observations in the multivariate
case. Right? I don't I don't want to get
hung up on deriving those necessarily.
There's some nice like in in um footnote
21 he he says look we can recover exact
using this notation we can recover
exactly what we did in chapter 2 as well
which is quite nice.
Okay I think it would be nice to now
look at figure 2.13 and just want to
admit some people admit admit admit.
Andrew sorry I see you have a question.
Oh yeah, no worries at all. I I didn't
want to
>> Oh, you I I can't hear you. Uh
>> oh,
>> you're unmuted.
>> Um
>> still now?
>> No, not working. Damn. Technical
difficulties.
>> I can hear Andrew.
>> Maybe maybe in the chat.
>> I can't hear Kobe either. Maybe it's
>> my Andrew as well. Yeah.
>> Okay. Uh microphone speaker,
can you uh just give me some sounds?
>> Check check check one too.
>> Not working.
>> Yeah, it seems all can hear me. It's
>> okay. Maybe I think it might be an issue
with me then. How unfortunate. Okay, you
can hear Andrew. Oh dear.
Oh well. Well, I may have to uh I tell
you what I'll do is I'll bring this down
here and I'll have a look at the chat.
That's probably what I'm going to have
to do.
Apologies all.
Get rid of that. Get rid of that. I'll
just
testing. Testing. One, two, three.
No. All right. We'll have to we'll have
to do without your your guys input
verbally, I'm afraid. That's very sad.
So,
all right. We can come back to it. Thank
you. I'll keep this open here so that I
do see people if they put questions in
the chat though. So, all right. Where
were we up to? Ah, yes. So, we we we end
this uh little bit here where we've
derived the posterior
uh distribution for the multiaried case.
He gives a sort of you know a land well
like a a map of all of the various ways
in which uh you know linear Gaussian
systems can can be used to formulate
inference uh problems more generally.
They're a very very very general way to
to sol you know specify and solve
inference problems. There's an enormous
family of of things that you can do
here. uh and you can basically spend you
know a college or university semester
just going down one of these branches.
Okay, but we see here that you know this
is kind of where these two branches here
is where expectation maximization live.
Okay, so we either know the parameters
in which case we can just do expectation
it's all very nice that's what we did in
chapter two or we don't know them and
then we have to estimate them and also
then do hidden state inference. Okay, so
we have this two-level problem. It's a
very nice dedactic picture. I I wouldn't
get too hung up on the details. It's
there essentially to to communicate the
very general setup that we're we're
swimming in here. There's a lot of stuff
that can be done. Uh but it doesn't have
to be mastered in order to do that.
The section ends with example 3.6 which
is I think you know quite nice. So
there's some things to show there. The
idea is here's the here's the actual
sort of figure.
uh there's a there's there's an irata in
this in the the caption for this figure
as well in terms of the spacing but it
doesn't matter uh very much. So the idea
here is that let's imagine that we have
a hidden states inference problem in
which the ca the hidden state is
two-dimensional. So there's two things.
There's the x position and there's the y
position. Okay, so we have a
multivariate hidden states inference
problem wherein there's only two hidden
states and the idea is that you're some
sort of creature, some little mouse down
there in the in the bottom left uh
trying to navigate around to to find
food. Okay, uh in this case the food is
a little piece of cheese and the idea is
that it's got some belief about where it
has previously seen cheese. Uh if we go
I believe it's 0.5 right in the center
there, that's the last known position of
the cheese. So that's kind of its prior
belief as to where it believes food uh
could be observed. Uh but on the basis
of sensory evidence, it needs to infer
the new position of uh of the cheese.
And you can see there's some bushes that
are of course obscuring the uh the real
the real position. Um,
with respect to this particular problem,
we're going to simplify it a little bit
and we're going to assume that, you
know, we have well, we got one state
vector produces many noisy observations
and we use a likelihood that that
factors across all of the given
observations that we can that we get.
Okay, so what is that? That's 3.37A.
Come down here. It's essentially the
same thing we did last time. So 3.378
this one here.
So this is what we're going to assume
our likelihood distribution is. Now it's
a product of independent likelihoods. So
I get some observation in uh on the
basis of the hidden state being
something that uh plausibly it might be
and we we multiply all of those things
together uh having you know on the basis
of each individual observation that we
get. Okay, that's an assumption about
how how the likelihood works. It could
be wrong. Okay, but it is a nice
simplifying one.
Uh, and then what you can do is you can
use those closed form updates I showed
you before 3.36 C and B setting the
matrix the the mixing matrix to be just
an identity matrix which effectively
acts like a one pretty much uh and no
bias.
And then you take the average overall
samples for the end samples. Uh and
there's some more analytical updates.
3.38A and B are shown but I don't want
to show those. I want to show them uh
what happens when you do this. Okay. So
we get figure 3.15.
So this is the result of performing
inference with uh under the multivariate
case basically where we've made our our
factorization assumption about the
likelihood. So what have we done? We've
taken 20 samples of the the problem 20
observations. So each one of these
little white dots is is an observation.
Okay? It's a it's a sample and on the
basis of that observation we're going to
update our belief about where we believe
the the hidden food is. So the actual
position of the hidden little piece of
cheese is the red uh the red plus. Uh
and having done having done inference uh
with with these 20 samples, we can see
that the actual distribution uh the
posterior about where we believe the the
food is is quite close to the true
position. It's not quite there. Um so
you know areas in in yellow are quite
high. They're quite peaked. We're
looking down on top of a a peaked
distribution here. Uh which is quite
nice. And this is in general, you know,
a lot of the problems that we care about
are are typically quite highdimensional.
They have a lot of axes of variability
in them. Going to be two or three or
five or even lots and lots of
dimensions.
All right. So that brings us to the end
of 3.4. Are there any questions about
anything so far? uh really that is just
a generalization of what we saw
previously
because that takes us to 3.5 which is
the the meat of the the chapter where we
actually talk about expectation
maximization
very very cool stuff
any questions I'll just briefly look at
the chat I am I do apologize for my uh
my audio not really working
chat
I do not see the chat okay
yeah may well maybe type out your
question, Andrew, or your your comment
and we can come back to it. I'll just
I'll just just maybe try and move that
for now.
Okay,
so section 3.5, this is the heart of the
chapter. This is where kind of
everything ties together. Um, and it's
where we talk about how to how to solve
this problem uh that we get when we're
doing when we do not assume that we know
the parameters. We have to learn them in
addition to doing our hidden state
inference. the the real benevolent point
is uh I I came to I've hammered it many
many times is uh in order to be able to
do hidden state inference we need to
know the parameters but in order to know
the parameters we have to also have the
result of hidden state inference so we
have this vicious kind of chicken and
egg problem and we're going to see
expectation maximization is what solves
this problem but before we do that
before we go straight to em he he takes
you through something called factor
analysis
initially. Um, and this is really just
it's the same thing as having a linear
Gaussian state space model except we
make certain assumptions, simplifying
assumptions that make the problem that
we're dealing with easier. So for
instance, I'll just really quickly well
I mean 3.39 is the relevant equation.
Come to there 3.39. There we 3.9
looking. It may not be in there just
yet. uh 37 38 C it's not in there just
yet that's fine it's not very
interesting to look at uh just yet but I
do want to read the simplifying
assumption
and I I want to also look at 3.16 that's
very helpful
figure 3.16
perfect
uh okay so you know we have two random
variables now the un the unobserved
vector okay the thing that we're trying
to do hidden state inference over and
the observed outcome that's the only
thing that we have is our observations
about light intensities. Um, very nice,
very nice.
Uh, yes. So, the thing that constitutes
the simplifying assumption in factor
analysis is that we assume that the
observation precision, so how spread out
our observation distribution, that's
this thing over here, uh, is diagonal,
meaning it's a matrix that just acts
like one. Um, but not all of the things
on the diagonal are the same value.
Basically, that's important.
>> [clears throat]
>> And then that results in 3.39 which is
the the observational likelihood that
we'll actually be using for factor
analysis. Uh the reason why factor
analysis is is useful is because it's
the first time well the first instance
of the problem wherein this circular
dependency of parameters and um hidden
states comes up. So this is this is
figure 3.16 here. This is a visual
representation. This is a Bayian uh
network which which visually shows you
the model at issue. Okay. Okay, so we
have this this particular motif here. So
X well Y depends on X. That's what the
arrow from X to Y means. And we would
read this as the likelihood. This is our
likelihood here. So this is the
probability of Yi given X I. All right.
And that's going to repeat I time or N
times. Okay. But of course X is so it's
a random variable meaning it gets a
circle. It depends on M and sigma X.
These are not random variables. So they
don't get circles. and obviously y
depends on the observation precision and
the mixing matrix. Okay, so this is this
a visual representation of of the
modeling setup that we're we're dealing
with.
It's always it's always nice to uh you
know meditate upon those things than it
is to look at inscrutable equations
initially
right here and then I'm going to show
you an incredible equation
3.4 uh sorry 3.40 40 this one here.
Yes. Okay.
So for our purposes 3.39 is the
multivariate form of hidden state
estimation from chapter 2 with a few
added constraints ones that I I
mentioned previously on the form of the
prior and the coariant structure. So
structurally each data point XI is
related to YI in this way here in in
equation 3.40. So this is really the
linear generating function from 3.39
which is boring to look at. This is kind
of what's inside it. So our observations
are generated by some parameter matrix
times our hidden states vector plus some
bias plus some Gaussian noise. Okay,
both of these things are vectors. Now
that's really all there is to that. And
then that results in the form of our
model that we used to do inference with
here which is 3.41.
So for you know for a single sample of X
and Y this model can be well
that that is what you
that is what you you have for a single
sample of X and Y there's a very well
and then he goes on to to specify the
the actual form of the model. Okay. So
mathematically this is the form we see
the parameters are theta and the
observation precision for our
observation likelihood. Okay. And that's
denoted by the superscript theta and
sigma y. Cool. There's an important
point here though uh that he mentions in
the text and he says note for this model
to be well specified D must be much
greater than C. Okay. So the
dimensionality of the observation vector
has to be quite a well bigger than or at
least quite a bit bigger than the
dimensionality of the hidden state
vector. That's actually quite important
for this to work at all. Um and again
see page 399 in appendix B for you know
what D and C are. Uh the idea there is
that you know we want uh to be able to
explain
uh hidden we we're assuming that the
hidden states there's some very small
number of hidden states that ex that
explain a very large number of
observations.
uh that's that's kind of the the
assumption that we're making here or
that would have to hold if if this is
going to be correct. So uh like you
might imagine I don't know what's what's
a good example
you you you need to uh like for instance
if if you're having a a psychometric
test
uh
one of one of these the constructs in
psychology for you know personality is
this big five model about what
personality is okay I'm not endorsing
this psychological construct or
critiquing it I'm just having it as an
example But the idea is okay well you
might sit down and be given a test which
has hundreds of questions on it might
have 100 questions or you know 200
questions whatever the idea is that
underneath all of those very large
number of observed things or observed
answers to questions 200 questions
there's really only five hidden states
that are generating those large number
of observations. So that's kind of the
assumption that we're making here is
that there's some small number of hidden
states which are generating a very large
number of observed behavior. Okay,
that's that's one very classic example
of uh of that of this this modeling
setup.
Just going to quickly check for
questions. There are some in the chat.
Lots I see Andrew's put his stuff there.
I simply wanted to say for those who are
still learning uh some of the things
very nice you got some clarifications
there. I'll put these in the notes as
well. That should be quite nice.
coariance and precision. Yeah, thank you
Andrew. Um,
a lot of the time, especially
uh here, you know, we're going to talk
about, okay, well, we're dealing with
Gaussian distributions, L-shaped things
in some number of dimensions, and they
have parameters. They have a mean and a
variance. Sometimes they're given as
having a mean and well, a mean and a
coariance. Sometimes they're given as
having a mean and a precision. And as
Andrew says there, you know, the
precision is just the inverse of the
variance. So I wouldn't get too hung up
on that just yet, but for those who are
looking at the mathematical details,
that is an important thing to keep in
mind.
Okay, chapter three.
I do apologize for my my lack of ability
to hear anyone.
Put uh put questions in your in the
chat.
Okay. And this this culminates then with
you know all right we can do the same
story again about what the posterior
distribution would be um in terms of its
parameters given the modeling
assumptions that we'd made in factor
analysis and that's 3.42A and B not too
instructive to look at but it maybe
would be nice to show them. Uh maybe we
don't have it though does sort things
strangely 3.42 4 to A and B. Maybe we
don't have them. Not too important. I
can add them in later as well.
Not there.
Not a problem.
Okay. Now 3.5.2. This is where we
actually define expectation maximization
and we uh we we tie everything together.
It's very it's very nice. Um,
with respect to that, there is a
subtlety though because we need a
likelihood to do these things. So, and
this is going to to cause a problem.
Just looking at time. We seem to be
okay. Equations. I do want to go to
3.43.
Hopefully, we have that.
3.4
3. No, maybe we don't. That's okay.
Well, anyway, the uh so 3.43 is we we we
have to start from our generative model
about what we have. So that all that is
is our likelihood times our um are
prior. I've already shown you those. I
don't want to go back over that. That's
going to take too much time to to define
through those things and way through the
maths.
But he says, look, we call this the
complete data likelihood, our our full
general model over hidden states and
observations. Um,
it's going to be nice to show something.
I'll just show a general model for now.
So, we have something like this. Okay,
something like this. This is not exactly
what we'd have. We have a complete data
likelihood. You know, it completely
describes everything about the data set
capturing all the variables involved in
the generation of an observation Y. But
really there are three variables whose
values are unknown. Okay, we have the
obviously the hidden state. We're trying
to infer that that's that's X. We have
you know some deterministic parameters
uh observation coariance right on on our
observation likelihood and the mixing
matrix theta of all the parameters that
we we saw before. Um and we don't know
the the the the mixing matrix theta or
the observation likelihood. And so that
gives rise to something called the
incomplete data likelihood. And that
would be a version of equation 3.43.
Uh and we're going to have to try and
use this somehow to do hidden state
inference and parameter learning. That's
kind of the the thing. But the problem
with that is that we can't uh we don't
we we need those parameters. And so
we're going to do it in two steps. I'm
going to come back to here. I have it in
my notes.
But 3.4 for wow 3.5 is where we are now
actually have the steps themselves here
we go so the first thing we're going to
do we're going to do expectation okay as
as the name suggests and this involves
uh this is on page 72 by the way there's
a kind of unofficial you know step one
expectation step two maximization and
then we we formalize it a bit more later
so we're going to infer hidden states
using the current estimates that we have
of our parameters so we don't know what
the parameters
Well, let's just randomly, you know,
initialize them to to something that's
going to be bad. And on the basis of
those beliefs about parameters, do
hidden state inference, right? So,
that's just good old hidden state
inference that we we we're used to. And
like conceptually, you know, what are
the hidden causes that best explain the
observations under the current belief
about parameters and that's going to be
bad. It's not going to be it's not going
to be very good. But we'll get we'll get
an answer. we'll get an answer about
what the the hidden states uh you know
are or belief about them and then once
we have that belief about the hidden
states we can then do maximization where
we using that subsequent belief about
the hidden states we update our belief
about the parameters okay um yeah I
should that should really be and the
parameters are the the theta mixing
matrix and the observation precision so
given given inferred hidden states how
should the model it itself change or how
should the parameters of the model
change? Uh and this is really powerful
because this means that we no longer
need uh both the parameters and the
hidden states in order to uh do the
inference that we want to do. We can
sort of break the problem up into two
independent things and then iteratively
perform this procedure. So you you're
going to have to do this procedure maybe
you know three, four, five, some number
of times. Okay, just doing it once is
not going to be ideal. very much like we
saw with gradient descent that's another
kind of iterative procedure as well
where you have to sort of turn the crank
a certain number of times.
Yeah. So expect expectation maximization
this this is a recursive problem now
where obviously you know the hidden
states depend on the parameters the
parameters depend on the hidden states
and you can get around the problem of
having to to infer both of them by
inferring one keeping one fixed doing
inference and then keeping that fixed
and doing maximization on the
parameters. That's the at least the uh
the qualitative story.
So the not the notation uh that is used
is
it's not my favorite but it is it is at
least um intelligible. So 3.44 four four
A and B which I don't know if we have
just yet
for one
not quite they give you the the the
analytical mathematical um well
description of of both steps basically
so not too important though uh the key
thing is once you've done all of that
you you now have your uh well uh 3.45 45
uh which I don't know if we have either.
No. So 3.45 that gives you the
analytical uh expression for the two
things you have to do in the expectation
step and then 3.46 A and B that gives
you your maximization step. That that is
all to say that we can summarize this
whole thing in terms of of an actual
algorithm. So algorithm three this is
presented here
is that it's down here actually we we
had to put it in
or not I I remember we did have it okay
maybe it's not here
or is it in the equations
we had it last week
okay
we'll have to we'll have to go I can put
that in algorithm two. Yeah, we don't
have it just now.
All that is to say is that uh this
culminates in algorithm 3 on page 73
where you know we have some sort of
pseudo code to to show uh the execution
of the ex uh you know expectation and
the maximization steps.
That is a shame. I thought we had it.
Okay.
And that is it. Basically, that is
chapter three done. There's some summary
and conclusions about, you know, what
we've done and why it matters. And then
there's some limitations about
expectation maximization. It's a great
procedure. It solves a lot of problems.
Um, but in order to be able to do the um
the expectation, you need to know the
posterior distribution kind of exactly.
And that's a bit of a that's a bit of a
trouble. that's usually not the case and
that motivates then the next chapter
chapter four where we begin to talk
about variational interests um and that
generalizes the situation or you know
opens up the space of problems that we
can solve uh there. So and that's what
we're going to dive into next time in
chapter 4 which really will be the
culmination of uh the mathematical
background for active inference. There's
a lot of things to learn in terms of uh
the constituents constituent
mathematical uh tools and so on and
chapter 4 will kind of be the end of
that and then we can use our knowledge
to start really thinking about active
inference per se that's going to be uh
very very cool. So, right. Yeah. Let me
just come to the chat. See if there are
any questions. Ah, go uh I lost how
access the collab notebooks. Andrew,
could you please point me again? Yeah.
Okay, we can uh we can do that. I
believe they're in they're in the coder
um Andrew, unless you you've changed
them before. See,
GitHub for the textbook group.
Yeah.
chapter the the well the exact ones that
he showed for chapter 2 they're they're
here as well. Um
we can go through this link though.
Yeah. So they're on they're on this page
here the uh the code page on the left
effectively. We're going to be uh that's
one thing I want to do uh going forward
is is make this much much nicer and a
bit more organized.
One thing I'm preparing to do is to
perhaps use manon uh which is a very
nice visualization library to to to show
uh the operation of a lot of these
procedures. It's very nice to see it
visually. Um
not so nice just to look at equations.
Ah one thing do uh so do put your
questions in the chat. One thing I did
want to note that is important. Let me
come back here
a little bit of time in in the notes.
I've gone down and this is this is
copied in both sections. Uh
I mentioned this last time there's some
additional resources in here about
mathematic. If you did want to
understand the mathematics in terms of
your linear algebra, I highly recommend
looking at these resources here. They're
very very helpful, very well regarded as
introductions. This particular series is
very good for visual intuition about
what's going on. Very light on on maths
like notation. That's excellent stuff.
So if you wanted to if you really truly
want to understand uh the operation of
these procedures, you really have to
understand matrix multiplication,
matrices, vectors, that kind of thing.
So highly highly recommend this these
resources here. Those are in the notes.
Now there [clears throat] are questions
for chapter 3. I haven't as of last week
I haven't answered the ones that were
there yet because they pertained to this
session. So all of the all of these
questions are are right for answering
now. So I will now go back and and go
over them unless there are any questions
from the chat. Perhaps we can go over
some of those and uh then we'll uh we'll
end the session.
I see. So Jen, do you have a question
about choice of distributional form?
That's an interesting question. Uh given
that we're doing linear Gaussian
systems,
was that in reference to to something?
If if I understand
what you mean by by your comment there,
is there any particular reason that the
whole algorithm is cast in terms of
normal? Yes, there is. Absolutely. Um so
if we go back down here,
not probably not going to be able to
find it in time. The answer is that
normal distributions, multivariate
normal distributions, um they are
mathematically quite nice in terms of
being able to work with them. Okay, they
give us analytical um you know closed
form uh expressions for things. So yeah,
they're very nice for that reason. And
indeed, one of the things that we've
seen kind of preview a bit is that they
give us a lot of um well, Beijian infant
with respect to Gaussian distributions
is conjugate. So if you have a b
gaussian prior and a gaussian likelihood
the posterior will be um a gaussian as
well which is very very nice property to
have other distributions exhibit that
property. So it's a very well- behaved
distribution. Um it's also very general.
So yeah for those reasons it's it's to
be favored and it's one of the reasons
why you can do so much you know this
this figure here it's one of the reasons
why you can do so much with them because
they are very general you know the
central limit theorem and all that. um
and they are they do play nicely
analytically with a lot of things. So
that's one of the great tragedies
actually of applied uh inference and so
on is that it's not always the case that
the probability distributions you want
to look at are Gaussian. You know you
might make that assumption and it could
be wrong. So we'll see that in
especially in chapter four. It's quite
quite a good preview for chapter 4. Is
there any work done with more general
distributions Libby and Parto? There
certainly is. Yes. Um although that's
getting into general questions about
variational inference now which we will
see that's that's chapter four. Um
absolutely. So there there is much more
work um in generalizing you know the the
class of things that we can do well a
class of um distributions with which we
can do inference. Yes for sure. Yeah.
But Gaussians are you know they're there
everywhere. That's what everyone starts
with. That's often what everyone assumes
in a lot of applications.
Is there a space of all distributions?
Uh are they a strong attractor? Well,
depends on how you parameterize that
question. Um certainly there is. If I go
there's there's some interesting
formulations of infants problems in
terms of something called information
geometry. Um where you imagine some
space or some surface and then a point
on that space or surface corresponds to
a probability distribution. Um there's
interesting things to be said there.
That's that's getting way out of our pay
grade just now. Um but yes, things have
been formulated in those terms and
indeed
I think versus white paper um I don't
know if I can find it in time. This one
here the only figure they had in this
whole paper. So this is an active
inference paper. You know this is a
position paper about how versus in
particular they're a company purporting
to do active inference. Um they show I
think is it just down here you know
let's imagine you have some space some
surface and points on that space or
surface are beliefs they're probability
distributions and that would mean that
walking around on that surface would
correspond to changing your beliefs.
Right? So you'd like to find some path
here that corresponds to, you know,
solving an inference problem. This in
this particular space, they're all
Gaussians, right? But you could have
another space where they're not or
something like that. So yeah, very
interesting stuff. But that's that's
quite that's a long way away for us.
I'll just reiterate. I mean the the the
thing about chapter 3 is like the core
thing to understand is that there is a
way to solve the problem that parameters
depend what hidden states depend on
parameters and that we also don't know
parameters and that is expectation
maximization. Uh that's kind of the crux
of chapter 3 if you wanted to sum it up
very concisely
and then we shall go into chapter four.
I'll just see is there any hope at all
of my speaker working? I don't think so.
All right. Well, I think I'll end the
recording here and then anyone who is
live who wants to ask questions, they
can.
uh which should be good. Other than
that, we will see everyone next week for
for chapter four. And chapter four is
going to be very crucial in terms of um
putting the cap on our ability to
understand the mathematics of active
inference. We're not going to see a lot
of new maths after that. Uh so that's
that's good. Yeah. All right, I shall
stop the recording.